Traduttore: Alberto Pagani
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Buonasera a tutti
guten Habend
good evening
konbanwa
masa' al-khair
boa tarde
potremmo dirlo in tante lingue...
Veniamo al dunque,
io guardo poco la televisione
ma ultimamente mi è capitato
qualche volta di accenderla
e devo dire che ho visto dei grandi orrori
che mi hanno sconvolto.
Ogni volta che accendo la televisione
vedo uccisioni, guerre, attentati,
cadaveri sparsi sulle nostre spiagge,
una cosa che stringe il cuore.
Una volta li chiamavano clandestini,
adesso è arrivato l'ordine
di chiamarli profughi.
Avevano anche fatto delle leggi
per criminalizzarli.
I profughi adesso
non li vuole ancora nessuno
però li chiamiamo profughi:
in Italia le cose cambiano nome
ma rimangono sempre le stesse.
Prendo l'autobus, e mi trovo davanti
una coppia abbastanza "abbronzata"
che parla fitto fitto
e io sono curioso di capire
da dove vengano.
Finalmente colgo una parola
che mi sembra di riconoscere:
"Ah sì, portoghese,
ma non è del Portogallo
e neanche brasiliano...
forse vengono da Capo Verde, chi lo sa"
Sono molto orgoglioso
di questa mia capacità,
anche senza parlare le lingue
di saperle riconoscere.
Ma in quel momento la mia attenzione
è captata da una signora, una matrona,
che squillantemente parla al telefonino
e dice qualcosa in una lingua
che è sicuramente slava
ma non è russo,
potrebbe essere ucraino,
l'aria della badante ce l'ha.
Poco più in là ci sono due ragazzi
che sembra stiano litigando di brutto,
in realtà sono due marocchini, evidentemente,
e i marocchini sembra sempre
che litighino
quando parlano, ma stanno sorridendo.
Insomma, sono orgoglioso
di questa mia capacità
e cerco di coinvolgere il mio vicino
che non mi sembra
altrettanto entusiasta.
Pensate che neanche lui parla italiano,
infatti a un certo punto sbotta a dire:
" 'sti marochän!
("Questi marocchini in dialetto bolognese)
Ch'al vagan a cà lór."
(Che se ne vadano a casa loro)
Ah, però questo non è italiano
ma bolognese, quindi è locale
e va bene.
Questo innesca un processo
che coinvolge altri personaggi sull'autobus,
per esempio uno che interviene dicendo:
"Brutta gente, tutti spacciatori,
portano via il lavoro agli italiani."
Allora io mi inserisco e dico:
"Perché, solo gli italiani
devono spacciare?"
(Risate)
Quello se ne va via sdegnato,
mi sembra di aver tradito la patria
quando dico queste cose.
Mi ricordo una volta, anni fa,
a una riunione del Quartiere Savena
c'era uno che tuonava
contro al fatto che in fondo
a Via Massarenti
c'era una moschea.
"C'è uno spaccio tremendo
in quella zona."
Al che io risposi:
"Anche in Piazza Verdi c'è spaccio
e c'è la chiesa
di San Giacomo Maggiore,
non capisco il nesso fra le due cose."
Mi guarda male perché ho interrotto
e in effetti sono stato maleducato
ma quando comincia a dire
che bisogna restituire
quei locali al comune
perché bisogna riaprire le scuole
dato che ci sono tanti bambini
nel quartiere,
non resisto, alzo la mano
e mi faccio dare la parola.
"Sono d'accordo
sulla riapertura delle scuole,
perché ci sono gli immigrati
che fanno tanti figli."
La gente mi guarda
con un po' di sussiego
però c'è qualcuno che si diverte
e sorride un pochino.
Noi italiani siamo brava gente,
non siamo razzisti,
tutti fratelli e tutti uguali certo,
magari quelli che hanno
la pelle così scura
non sono tanto uguali
e se hanno la pelle scura
magari una ragione ci sarà.
Noi siamo un popolo di santi, poeti, navigatori,
siamo eredi di una tradizione culturale
bellissima, greco-romana, cattolica.
"Lei va sempre in chiesa la domenica?
Si accosta ai sacramenti?" No...
"Però legge la Divina Commedia!
Ah, non si intende di teatro... Ho capito."
Siamo un popoli pieno di contraddizioni
e quando Totti fa un goal
siamo pronti a sbandierare
il tricolore come dei disperati
poi quando in realtà sentiamo parlare
una persona con un accento meridionale
allora diventiamo padani
e "i terroni che vadano a casa loro."
Tutti devono andare a casa loro,
vogliamo che questa gente
non resti qui da noi.
Non li vogliamo
perché ci mettono in crisi,
sono diversi da noi,
fanno cose strane, hanno lingue strane,
usi strani, che vadano a casa loro.
Gli islamici soprattuto
vadano a casa loro.
Io mi ribello a questo punto,
innanzi tutto se parliamo italiano
non si dice gli islamici
perché islamico è un aggettivo
che si riferisce a cose.
Si dice musulmano,
ma a parte questo
io che cosa faccio?
Dove vado?
Sono già a casa mia.
La costituzione mi garantisce
la libertà di culto,
c'è l'articolo 3 che lo dice.
Ah, ma la costituzione
è ora di cambiarla...
è vero, perché è invecchiata.
Veramente non siamo ancora riusciti
ad applicarla tutta.
Ero sempre stato convinto che
i nostri uomini politici
avessero fatto un ottimo lavoro
con la costituzione.
Ma cambiamola,
eliminiamo la libertà di culto,
cacciamo gli islamici,
poi cacceremo via gli ebrei, gli zingari,
gli handicappati...
qualcosa che ho già sentito
da qualche parte mi pare.
Ma la storia non ci insegna gran che.
La storia non è maestra di vita in realtà.
Nessuno la vuole come maestra di vita
perché tutti sanno sbagliare da soli,
senza bisogno di aiuto.
E poi in genere la gente dice:
"A me questo
non potrebbe capitare mai."
Penso ancora
a quei due ragazzi marocchini
sull'autobus: quando andiamo
alle feste multietniche
mangiare cous cous insieme
ci fa sentire tutti buoni e fratelli,
però devono tornare
anche loro a casa loro.
Non importa se con il loro lavoro
pagano le pensioni agli italiani,
se con il loro lavoro pagano
le tasse che gli italiani evadono,
che fanno mestieri
che gli italiani non vogliono fare.
Soprattutto non dimentichiamoci
che vengono non solo per lavorare,
vengono soprattutto per sopravvivere,
perché nelle loro case
non possono più stare.
Forse non ci sono neanche più
le loro case
in alcune situazioni.
Vengono perché possono morire
da un momento all'altro
mentre noi produciamo tante armi
ma non le usiamo a casa nostra,
le vendiamo agli altri.
C'è un'intera industria delle armi
che fa morire migliaia di persone
in giro per il mondo.
Loro vengono perché i loro bambini
quando giocano nel prato
qui non rischiano di trovare
una mina antiuomo
che gli scoppia in faccia.
Noi nel 1994 quando ci fu l'embargo
sulla produzione delle mine antiuomo
noi abbiamo visto un'azienda intera,
la Valsella,
che è fallita perché non aveva più
fatturato sufficiente.
Quando è fallita si è scoperto
che avevano mandato illegalmente,
via Singapore,
nove milioni di mine antiuomo in Iraq.
I dirigenti lo ammisero,
furono processati e naturalmente assolti.
Noi cosa possiamo dire a questo punto?
È vero che il problema è
"ognuno a casa sua"...
se la casa ci fosse.
In realtà il problema dell'immigrazione
negli ultimi anni è diventato
estremamente complesso.
Complesso perché questa gente
viene da paesi diversi,
ha lingue diverse, tradizioni diverse,
non vengono da un unico paese.
Vengono da 197 paesi diversi:
ci sono residenti in Italia che vengono
addirittura da posti che si chiamano
Palau, Vanuatu, Tuvalu, Nauru...
credo che non molti sappiano
dove si trovano queste località.
In Italia ci sono attualmente
oltre cinque milioni di stranieri residenti,
l'otto percento della popolazione italiana.
E non è strano che i bambini stranieri
nelle scuole possano essere il dieci percento
di una classe ormai,
perché gli stranieri naturalmente
fanno più figli di noi.
Quello che ci dimentichiamo di ricordare
è che nel mondo esistono
ottanta milioni di persone
oriunde italiane.
Ottanta milioni di persone
che hanno almeno un nonno
di origine italiana
o italiano.
E che nel 1860
quando ci fu l'unità d'Italia
la popolazione italiana era circa
trenta milioni.
Fino alla fine del secolo
dieci milioni di persone
emigrarono in America...
Brasile, Argentina,
Uruguay, Stati Uniti.
È una pagina di storia
che sui nostri libri di scuola
non si legge.
Anche se dobbiamo solidarietà
a queste persone,
per semplice fattore umano,
dobbiamo anche cercare di ricordarci
che la solidarietà non si esprime
attraverso gli aiuti umanitari,
non si esprime attraverso
le missioni di pace.
Gli aiuti umanitari
servono a sentirci buoni, coinvolti,
poi lasciano il tempo che trovano
e le missioni di pace
le compiono soldati armati fino ai denti
con i carri armati.
Non ho capito che pace sia
quella con le armi.
Quello che veramente
sarebbe importante
è avere una scuola diversa,
che rispondesse ai bisogni
di un dialogo,
di una corretta informazione,
di un interscambio che porti
all'integrazione di queste persone.
Perché forse abbiamo dimenticato
la differenza che c'è
fra integrazione e assimilazione.
Abbiamo dimenticato la differenza
fra tolleranza e rispetto.
Nelle nostre scuole, come sappiamo,
ci sono tanti insegnanti precari
e comunque gli insegnanti
sono sottopagati.
Mentre le spese militari
nessuno le mette in discussione,
ogni volta che c'è da fare
un discorso sulla scuola
pare che i soldi non ci siano mai.
La scuola invece ha bisogno
di una nuova dimensione
e di un nuovo modo di confrontarsi
con queste realtà.
Quello che noi vediamo
è che la storia si fa in modo sbagliato:
si fa la storia a partire dall'Europa.
A partire da quelle che sono le situazioni
che ci sono in Europa
o nei paesi dove gli europei
hanno sterminato le popolazioni locali.
Nelle nostre scuole
cosa sappiamo per esempio
di quello che è avvenuto in Messico
mille anni fa? Chi c'era?
Si parla della civiltà Maya?
E duemila anni fa in Cina chi comandava
quando c'era l'impero degli Han?
E quattromila anni fa in Egitto,
quando già avevano costruito
le grandi piramidi?
Quando si fa matematica a scuola
si dice, per esempio,
quando studiamo algebra
o trigonometria o i logaritmi,
che impariamo delle cose
che sono state inventate
da matematici arabi?
E che quando parliamo di astronomia
i nostri astronomi usano
duecento nomi di stelle
arabi?
Quando parliamo
della rivoluzione copernicana
ci dimentichiamo che ci fu un astronomo
cinquecento anni prima di Keplero,
che però scriveva in arabo purtroppo
che si chiamava Al-Biruni,
e che non sfigurerebbe accanto
a Copernico, a Galilei.
Tutti noi sappiamo
cos'è successo nel 1492,
Cristoforo Colombo scopre l'America.
Cos'ha scoperto non lo so
perché c'erano da quarantamila anni
popolazioni che abitavano in quei luoghi.
Scopre l'America ma non lo sa
perché credeva
di essere arrivato in Cina.
Ma quanti sanno che nel 1260
avvenne una battaglia famosa
in altre parti del mondo
che ha cambiato le sorti dell'Europa?
Le orde mongole
del nipote di Gengis Khan
erano arrivate quasi
alle spiagge del Mediterraneo,
si sarebbero imbarcate
e avrebbero intrapreso la conquista
e il saccheggio d'Italia e d'Europa.
Furono fermati a Ain Jalut
da un sultano mamelucco
che si chiamava Qutuz
che cambiò le sorti del mondo.
Chi ne ha mai parlato nelle scuole?
Credo che questo tipo di rapporto
nella scuola,
dove ogni persona
possa avere diritto di parlare
e di sentirsi un essere umano
considerato e interessante da ascoltare,
porterebbe a un interscambio diverso,
a un altro modo di rapportarci
con chi è diverso da noi
arricchendo entrambi
perché anche noi impareremmo
a capire meglio chi siamo noi stessi
e qual è la nostra cultura.
E capiremmo
che queste grandi differenze
nel mondo non ci sono
anche perché il mondo è diventato
un villaggio globale ormai.
Un villaggio globale dove
tutto interessa a tutti
perché globalizzazione
non deve significare
omologazione culturale
come denunciava
cinquant'anni fa Pasolini.
Il rischio dell'omologazione culturale
è che spariscano tutte le culture
e vengano assimilate
da un'unica cultura dominante.
Abbiamo imparato che
la biodiversità è un valore necessario
per preservare
il nostro pianeta nel futuro,
per portarlo a una situazione
vivibile anche per i nostri figli.
Quello che succede nel resto del mondo
riguarda noi personalmente,
come sarà il mondo di domani
riguarda ciascuno di noi
individualmente e personalmente.
Se in Sierra Leone accade qualcosa,
anche se non sappiamo
dove sia la Sierra Leone
sicuramente avrà delle ricadute
anche sul nostro modo di vivere.
Non sarà che questa biodiversità
che abbiamo accettato,
che consideriamo positivamente,
sia qualcosa che deve farci accettare
anche l'importanza
della diversità delle culture
e il mantenimento della diversità
delle culture nel mondo?
Grazie
(Applausi)